good morning welcome to all out politics
and we start with some breaking news uh
downing street has insisted that people
should continue to self-isolate when
told to do so by the nhs
app it follows suggestions this morning
from the small business minister paul
scully that it was up to employers and
individuals to decide what to do when
people are pinged by the
test and trace app but a number 10
spokeswoman said
isolation remains the most important
action people can take to stop the
spread of the virus
given the risk of having and spreading
the virus when people have been in
contact with someone with covid
it's crucial that people isolate when
they're told to do so
either by nhs test and trace or by the
nhs covid app
businesses should be supporting
employees to isolate they should not be
encouraging them to break
isolation well joining us now is our
political correspondent tomorrow cohen
um all rather awkward really it is
and this is all over the question of
whether self-isolation which as we know
has become a massive problem for
businesses for school children
we've got half a million people at home
self-isolating probably
the same number at the moment with covid
where does that go and the small
business minister
said that self-isolation is advisory and
that is indeed the case in fact the
prime minister was asked about it at a
press conference
last week but downey street have been uh
very annoyed by the idea that that
allows
people to somehow get out of it um and
in fact
i don't know how downing street will
feel about the fact that one of their
own ministers has apparently written to
manufacturers
uh lord grimstone uh an investment
minister has written to manufacturers
saying that uh they
it is up to them whether they want to
apply but it does sound absurd that
on the one hand we've got downing street
being very heavy-handed
saying yes if you get pinged you've got
to isolate
yet we've got the government uh
discussing exceptions for people working
in the health service we've got a plan
to drop it
anyway in the middle of august uh for
people who've been double vaccined and
then on top of that
you know people are seeing on television
mass crowds
not self-isolating perfectly legally in
clubs it doesn't seem to make sense
no i think um the pictures we saw
yesterday and
of course the picture from wembley will
make people think that for
some life has has gone back to normal um
the government insists that the
self-isolation policy will continue
until
the 16th of august when it may be
replaced with with testing instead
but downing street say that the
list of exemptions which we're going to
get today apparently
of parts of the economy that can be
exempt
is going to be very tightly drawn it's
not going to be like the key workers
list we saw at the beginning
of the pandemic i was told it's not
going to be journalists like us
it's not going to be ministers and
people in downing street who are exempt
from self-isolation it's going to be
really key people people involved in
food production people running
nuclear power plants and so on it's
going to be very tightly drawn but i'm
sure there's going to be a real
scramble to get some of those places and
how's this plan
i think what is it the end of september
beginning of september is it for people
who want to go to nightclubs and other
crowded indoor venues
uh how's that going going yes so to have
to have a passport
indeed after months of saying covered
passports were not going to happen
uh boris johnson said yesterday that
nightclubs would have to
have them so you'd have to have had two
jabs have the covered passport
on your phone now this will have to get
through a vote in parliament and that
will be tricky because a lot of
conservatives
don't like what they see as id cards uh
by the back door
labour have not said whether they will
support it they want to see what the
proposal
is first and indeed point out that
testing might be important
as well since two jabs doesn't prevent
you guessing or transmitting
covid so is this going to happen well
not for a couple of months
so there'll be plenty of super spreading
according to patrick valance
before then and you do wonder whether
the government just really hope that
venues are going to just bring it in
voluntarily over the next
couple of months and that with enough
people vaccinated this may not have to
happen because it's going to be
a very difficult policy to bring in
how to enforce it and of course you're
going to get a lot of opposition in
parliament